qui a dit elle remue ses fesses
Francesca sur Aya Nakamura c'est
Nicoletta bravo
[Applaudissements]
alors il est vrai
Nicoletta a violent ah tu veux dire
attends je vais juste te dire ça
Nicoletta violemment critique Aya
Nakamura Nicoletta on la connaît on
l'adore célèbre chanteur deux trois
titres le soleil il est mort le soleil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est la
musique mamie blue
j'adore ça
alors dans un premier temps disait que
la chanteuse Aya Nakamura ne chante pas
bien vous vouliez réagir Florent ouais
parce qu'elle sait surtout pris à la
gestuelle et aux chorégraphies d'Aya
Nakamura qu'elle se touchait un peu le
sexe et vulgaire
etc et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'elle a été Aya Nakamura était
défendue par Anne Roumanoff ensuite qui
a comparé ça une forme de racisme
sous-jacent en disant que ce qu'elle
avait déclaré était extrêmement
tu as raison il se trouve que Anne
Roumanoff quand elle est agi c'était
dans mon émission sur RFM dimanche
dernier et tu sais avec vous mais oui
mais elle n'a pas critiqué Nicoletta
anormanov elle a simplement défendu Aya
Nakamura elle a défendu maintenant elle
a pas cité Nicoletta non non elle a pas
cité Nicoletta je sais même pas si elle
pensait à Nicoletta elle était agacée
que l'on attaque tout le temps Aya
Nakamura parce qu'elle aime beaucoup
parce qu'elle trouve que c'est une
liberté de la femme
noir qui a les grosses vendeuse de
disques et qu'elle cartonne mais à
chaque fois ici tout le monde le racisme
c'est une femme noire c'est une femme
qui cartonne c'est une femme qui ne
s'excuse pas de cartonner donc voilà ça
je ne dis pas qu'elle est raciste
Nicoletta je veux dire en général que
tout le monde a des conneries quand on
connaît le passé de Nicolas
elle est elle est franchement
tout sauf raciste
on n'a jamais dit qu'elle était raciste
hein c'est latitude elle n'aime pas le
comportement de Aya Nakamura
[Rires]
a raison il est c'est vrai que c'est un
problème de génération Jean-Michel non
c'est pas que ça je suis désolé c'est
pas une question de raciste c'est que
Aya Nakamura récolte un peu ce que la
sommet c'est qu'elle est réputation de
diva des tresses nobles de ce snober son
public
elle a une mauvaise réputation
elle consacre pas de temps c'est fans
qui l'attendent parfois 4 heures quelque
part parce qu'elle arrive elle passe
sans les regarder etc
calme-toi toi
que c'est une question de génération
parce que toi qui a un certain âge non
parce que je le reconnais du talent elle
est formidable
j'adore Aya Nakamura je parlais pas de
ses talents de chanteuses c'est une très
bonne chanteuse moi je l'adore je
l'adore mais quand tu regardes Nicoletta
tu regardes les samedis dernier The
Voice elle est effectivement la plus
froide de tous les participants qui
étaient venus et c'est pas un jugement
sur son talent on passe en direct
des câlins à tous les candidats pour
être respecté en chanteuse mais elle
doit pas avoir un prix de l'amitié
c'est pas qu'elle faisait la tronche
c'est que juste que dans ces clips dans
ses chansons elle est vulgaire
c'est dans le mouvement de maintenant tu
vois je reconnais que ça peut paraître
il suffit de regarder Instagram ou
TikTok qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est dans
la mouvance de maintenant c'est c'est la
mouvante américaine et Beyoncé par
moment c'est pareil alors pourquoi on va
critiquer Aya Nakamura qu'est-ce qu'il a
dit qu'on est l'euro
peloter durant tes clip tu as le droit
de le faire
j'aurais pas dû lui demander je suis
désolé non Claude le débat parce que je
sens que ça commence à déraper mesdames
messieurs pardon c'est moi qui dirige
cette émission